this is much more than a simple video
game this is Ian Burkhart
and he's paralyzed from the neck down
and magically he's also shredding in
2010 a diving accident left Ian's
quadriplegic for years later doctors
implanted an array of electrodes in his
brain specifically the motor cortex a
team of scientists then used machine
learning algorithms to decode Ian's
brain activity it can use those signals
to control his forearm muscles with this
stimulation sheet for 15 months in had
to learn how to think about moving his
arm is enhanced he got better at
thinking and the computer got better at
reading his thoughts now he can
manipulate all sorts of things
scientists have developed similar
systems using robotic arms but this is
the first time they've ever been able to
restore movement in a paralyzed limb
Ian's progress is huge not only for the
researchers but for all those affected
by paralysis
today it's Guitar Hero tomorrow it could
be standing and walking and sure maybe
some Guitar Hero 2